we might be drunk we
might be drunk as long as we
are hanging out you know we might be
drunk
raise a glass let's talk [ __ ] head peeps
wrecks and a bit
maybe drunk we might be
drunk yeah
[Music]
look at us we're [ __ ] we're doing
[ __ ] we're doing [ __ ]
nobody does [ __ ] we're doing [ __ ]
everybody talks about i'm writing a
screenplay i'm working on a documentary
there are documentaries that's true
that's true wait are we on are we on oh
oh great good
good hey we're doing stuff hey cheers
first in person man i know this is great
we got a studio we're in in manhattan
we got chairs oh that's good stuff man
hang on a little a little sour mash
oh owens creek all right thank you thank
you phineas who brought us this bottle
here and for the studio for the studio
i'm loving it
so man this is nice this is this is a
real step up where we're trying folks we
read every comment they were hurtful
i didn't read any of the comments don't
read them why why are you reading
comments
well i mean once you get through the
anti-semitism there's uh there's some
actual
good critiques some some constructive
these these guys are terrifying online
because they're sitting in a basement in
milwaukee
but if some people are like hey i can't
hear this or
that was out of frame or whatever it is
so i read them
yeah i i don't think you could read them
because when you start with those you
never stop
that's true that's true it starts with
youtube comments where does it end
yeah good point good point well i read
you know i put my special on youtube and
i've read every comment
wow so if you commented on that i liked
it or didn't like it
and you can go check that it's gonna be
a little thumbs up but it's gonna have
my name next to it
you're the most successful human being
who does that
i don't think anyone else i'll take it i
don't think anyone else has the time
how do you write this many jokes and
read i think when i'm at the airport or
something i'm like let me look at the
special
you know and i have youtube uh
notifications on my phone so i can just
look at it right when they come in
i'll peak occasionally but i'm in and
out yours are good
i've looked at yours and i wrote it
you're looking at mine too well i look
at everybody it's like i want to get a
big
deal what is going on i mean if i owned
a restaurant i'd be reading yelp
it's different i think yeah it i guess
it is because there's more comments
and there's more and also like
restaurants
do should respond to criticism more than
more than entertainers we're artists
at the end of the week i don't go that
far but we're entertaining we're
creatives
you know we're making uh something that
wasn't there before we're the lowest
carlin said we're the lowest level
artists
we are treated the lowest but i think
we're maybe the hardest working
and somebody said stand up to the
warriors of show business which you know
we're out in the [ __ ] boonies in
youngstown ohio in
a in a [ __ ] condo i think i heard
that i think it was robert klein who
said he was
we were the warriors of show business
the gladiators and the story he told was
like i was in a limo with meryl streep
and we're like
yeah it sounds like you're really uh
hitting it hard there yeah yeah
but you know we're out every night we
write it we perform it we get drunk we
do drugs
fat chicks i mean you can the list goes
on of just
machete swipes through a jungle that is
that's we are warriors holy [ __ ]
yeah now uh you know what i can play we
really
we really do i think we have to drink
people give a [ __ ] but then i was
telling a friend
recently like man i might be drinking
too much and he goes yeah but you guys
work hard
that's true that's true you gotta if
you're like a
you know if you're a stock trader you
hit happy hour don't you
good point yeah work hard play hard and
a big part of our job is humiliation
like that's just part of it you bomb a
joke it stings it hurts you're doing
badly the crowd's not laughing
so we gotta cut that edge somehow big
big part of our job
also a big part of our hotel room
afterwards yes
you got that right yeah blue chew hook
us up
i still haven't tried it i want to try
oh man i got a girlfriend and i'd do it
for fun
you got to try it man i'm scared cause i
i was talking to our boy anthony devito
and he told me that
he took a viagra and he was hard for
like 48 hours
wow the whole movie
[Laughter]
i mean like man you have some weird
racist fetishes here anthony this is
crazy
nick nolte yeah nalty was the man that
was you re-watched that one and you're
like there's
a lot of racism that one is still you're
like damn
even even for the even for an 80s cop
yeah
the the last glimmer of that was in uh
die hard three where he has the i hate n
words in harlem
remember that yeah even as a kid i was
like this is a little heavy
i know but it was a different time that
was pretty insane yeah that was
40 hours was a good movie though oh yeah
and i like die hard 3 2 but if you
rewatch it some of them like
that whole scene i could be wrong with
that whole scene in die hard 3
when bruce willis and samuel l jackson
figure out like
there's a bomb going to go off and they
had to figure out how to get the amount
of water it's like a
puzzle this is really annoying yeah i
didn't think that made sense
right like pushed it together at the
last minute like yeah we do this and we
do that and like that didn't work yeah
and and how much time do these criminals
have on their hands like we need a
puzzle
we gotta create a riddle like no they
just want money
they're just trying to steal stuff i
never got that by the way kind of a fun
fact about white people
if you had a i hate honky sign in the
middle of the burbs
i don't think we would do much about it
which depends which suburb you're
talking like columbia south carolina
that might be an issue that's a good
point yeah it depends on the suburb yeah
yeah but if it was like if it was a
liberal suburb they'd be like right on
absolute white family be like absolutely
that's a good point
yeah yeah and they'd they'd get next to
them and make one themselves
it's like i'm with him with a finger
remember i'm with stupid whatever
happened to that shirt i think it was
one of those shirts that wasn't funny
yeah and it became maybe stuck around
because it was like well this isn't
funny but i'll wear it as a joke
yes it got a second bump maybe
ironically
right right i went on ebay a couple
years ago and bought uh the the finger
pointing down and said legend
did you really yeah i never wore it but
i bought it legend
yeah like point i don't even have a big
dick i just thought it was a such a
ridiculous shirt
is it one that said the man the legend
or just legend oh might be the man the
legend yeah it might be man legend
it's still in the package those are the
only it's funny that who's buying those
shirts they must do well because they
sell well
yeah like bourbon street or times square
yes well
it's it's the the non-funny guy gets it
and the
funny guy gets it so it's a pretty good
ploy because you know one guy's ironic
and one guy's sincere
i'm from new york you [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah
that's another one
i'm from new york city duck [ __ ]
i wonder if anyone's ever been shot in
the head while wearing that shirt oh
that'd be a viral clip
that would be pretty good boob inspector
was a big one for a minute
fbi federal yeah a female body inspector
body inspector yeah my uncle had one of
those
that's such an uncle shirt it really is
you know fisherman guy
uh has a boat the whole thing yeah i'm
gonna guess your uncle is unmarried
no no no he's married i mean it's
louisiana so it's true
he's like the mayor
yeah you don't have any i mean do you
have southern relatives no
um oh uh oh we got long island we got
some israeli oh wow never been to israel
yeah i'd love to go i'd love to go
that'd be a fun that'd be a fun gig
oh man i mean i hear the city is
beautiful i hear the food's great the
women are beautiful
i hear the food is on another level i
would love to those beaches i mean it's
no wonder the palestinians
get a little peeved because uh they just
got sand and
then jerusalem is like tel aviv it's
like new york i was thinking about this
like they can't agree on land they can't
agree on food
because they have similar menus the
palestinians hummus and grape leaves
falafels who started it yeah i'm sure we
could figure this out with a simple
google search
yeah but who started
i was like shawarma who claims shawarma
i would assume it's palestine because
they were there first and it might be
something with the the climate and the
geography what grows there
because jews were given that area right
this is not a historical show no no no
oh boy let's see
how are you on this give it a goog let's
see what we got
all right uh well isn't that the whole
beef that hey this is ours and just
because they gave it to you it's still
technically ours and you're
on our turf you should know this this is
your aunt we're talking about
what uh call in if you know somebody
right now is
yelling at the tv in in hebrew
who started it who started
that's a funny way that's a good one see
who uh who started it who's in a war
yeah i'm getting persian persians
a third third runners entered the race
good rugs um persian rugs that's really
it's weirdo places are known for like
one thing yeah that's true
that's true brazilians wax we all think
of the crotch
yeah interesting they've got more to
offer yeah they've got great steaks and
stuff
great steaks yeah dancing mardi gras
like carnival is brazilian the greatest
spreading covid
yeah you're the best yeah no one is
better than brazilians at spreading
coven
florida's on the on the rise but yeah
yeah and wuhan might be third
man but yeah it's it's brazil wuhan and
uh orthodox
jewish weddings that's really those are
like
the hot spots yeah that's a good point
those jews i mean i was i told you i was
on a flight and there was like [ __ ]
orthodox
temple and every mass was down here and
i was i was loving watching it because
the the stewardess of the flight
attendant was like
sir please oh yeah i'm gonna get [ __ ]
from this podcast for sitting with a
gentile who goes those
jews i'm gonna get [ __ ] for that yeah
yeah
well people think you're jewish i know
which is a i take as a compliment
it is a conflict it's like when someone
calls you gay and you're like yeah it's
not
that's a great point have you seen gay
guys they're ripped they got
fashion yeah they're groomed very well
groomed
yeah and gay guys get it like they could
clean up with the ladies
they really could oh yeah you ever see
like a gay guy just reach for like a
woman's breast and you're like come on
that's not fair that's a mean trick it's
not fair
yeah i don't even like when babies do it
you know they're grabbing at your mom's
tit you're like hey
i know you're two months but get your
hand off that nip
it kind of feels like a waiter just
walking over and taking a bite and
you're like
i was gonna try right right i have to
have some charm and finesse or buy a
meal
you get to just you know pay for it yeah
you
[ __ ] cuomo cuomo is hanging in there
yeah yeah yeah i'm starting it's at the
point where i am starting to
i don't like him but it's he's scoring
some points with me
just here's here's what happened i think
we might have talked we there's a
problem with this podcast we drink
every week so we don't remember what we
talked about
um i know i'm trying to pace too because
i could
put this down and it's really two gulps
yeah um
but yeah he's hanging in there oh yeah
oh yeah and
and i will say in his defense like the
first two you're like ooh that's bad
you're groping you're touching
you're kissing uh without consent but
then after
the ninth one it was like he said hi to
me while i was on a phone call and i
didn't appreciate it
like come on these are getting a little
too the waters are getting muddy here
yeah he asked me if i had any weekend
plans like that could have been like
small talk yeah
he is a bad guy it's funny i was talking
to a woman recently he was like i think
he's so hot
what yeah get out of town i mean serial
killers have fans
that's true that man women are [ __ ]
kooky
you can't put a you can't put a stamp on
women because they're all so different
women are kooky they're so well they're
so broad and fast
you sound like a 70 year old road comic
you ladies are real kooky
i'll tell you that well pull me off with
a cane when i'm done but
uh yeah it's just fascinating like you
watch the richard
ramirez doc and they're in the the
jewelry like
i'm like this guy murdered 28 people and
shot a guy in the face and all this [ __ ]
that guy
night stalker night stalker great
they get the coolest names like marvel
heroes i know it's [ __ ]
yeah they really like they're doing
their own pr it's crazy
i can't i pay for pr i can't get [ __ ]
like that yeah sunnyside killer what is
that one of them or the
sun oh what's the one in california
sunset the east area rapist east area
rapist
that's not a good one though that's just
the location and rapist that's not that
good
that's true yeah horrible real estate
uh what's that one harry with the uh
no i've never even heard of that one
that sounds like a good comic sunset
strip killer
golden state killer i mean that's that's
pretty badass
that does sound badass yeah like the
shang wang story or something he's just
like a funny
oh he's from sf right right
great comic oh yeah yeah yeah um dude
he's got he's got some of the best jokes
he's a joke about you know asian guy
he's dr he's taking his bicycle
and uh someone yells at him ching chong
[ __ ] and he goes my name is
shang wang
yeah you're gonna have to come with me a
little harder than that dude that's a
great joke
great joke he's a beast underrated i
love him i think he's got a half hour on
comedy center yeah he's got albums and
stuff he's a b he opened for ali wong
and stuff
oh perfect but he's all over he's a
great comic real
real comic to the bone too because uh
one time we were talking he's like i got
a gig to ride on
um off the boat yeah and he's like
should i just keep voting for
ally or do that and i was like i don't
know that's pretty good money and he
he turned it down yeah respect
respect and i mean who's who's really
watching off the boat
i think it's pretty big oh is it oh
isn't it huge
that's got to be over was it let's look
it up i bet it's in season seven right
now
but sitcoms are done i feel like for
real tv went drama like the drama killed
it breaking bad and mad men
and sopranos and all that and the comedy
went to hell
there's good comedy but it's just hard
like i mean i guess
when's the last do you even watch comedy
anymore though i do i'm
i'm a nerd but like new comedy i mean
like new comics sitcoms are you talking
about stand up
new comp new sitcoms no that's my point
there's i think there's still good
comedy out there it's just harder it's
harder to get made
i know but i don't feel like i hear
people like you gotta watch this
documentary you gotta watch this new
show
on netflix or whatever hbo but i don't
hear anybody going this sitcom is
killer like peep show was the last funny
show that i was recommended and i
enjoyed it
but that's it yeah it's incredible it's
incredible i fell in love with it it's
it's maybe it's probably top five
comedies for me it's
the development those guys are such
those guys like they really nailed it
they're such those characters and you
you you feel like you know him i mean
it's so good
i really wanted to make a version of
that with me and mackie like an
americanized version of it because
mackie is that dude yeah joe mackey is
mark right he totally is he knows
history
he's a square square yeah and he's got
the big eyes and like everything's
it's the exact same tucks his shirt in
for something i love that yeah
dude it's hard to find a good comedy
you're right i mean dramas are
and docs are kind of where it's at now
docs are great again authenticity people
want the real [ __ ] now we we had that
reality tv horseshit
they do when they don't though don't you
i mean don't you long for script i mean
i
reality is horse [ __ ] but i long for
great scripted television i do comedies
they are hard to make
succession is kind of a comedy though i
love succession that's kind of a comedy
you're rick yeah it's got
hilarious moments but that's like
shakespearean
comedy yeah i feel like that's
everything that's one of those like
dramedies it's got everything you need
love and all that [ __ ] but you're right
game of thrones was a huge show and the
biggest movie in the country right now
is godzilla
we need an escape who gives a [ __ ] about
godzilla versus king kong
i never cared less about a thing i'm so
with you i don't like marvel i don't
like any of that [ __ ]
i don't like godzilla you're losing
brain cells watching that
more quickly than we are drinking
it is like you're like i want to be
dumber and watch this [ __ ]
like i'm not i'm not even a snob but i'm
like can we can we get some good [ __ ]
i get nothing out of that there's no
relatability there's no human
in this it's just screaming animals
breathing fire stepping on buildings
at some point nostalgia becomes like an
issue for me or at some point like we're
taking it too far
the other godzilla movie from the 90s
with matthew broderick [ __ ] blue
oh yeah i never got i hated all of it i
i don't like any of that [ __ ] but this
is what the public wants
yeah now where do you stand on kung fu
because it's it's good i like it i never
like kung fu because i feel
it's the same to me it's just like hike
check check i need some development i
need some humanity i need some feelings
some vibes some something
i like the classics i mean bruce lee was
the [ __ ] i mean i like like
like yeah well yeah like enter the
dragon's a classic i liked for a while
ago if you see him in the theater like
and [ __ ] like that those were cool
movies i thought but i
yeah i mean you're seeing them for the
stunts i guess it's not my it's not my
cup of tea but i can appreciate it
all right i guess i like good we like
writing we like dialogue like
you know like a woody allen or something
like that but you know i'm a [ __ ] i
i i don't care about an explosion it
does nothing for me
yeah i don't know no you're right i mean
it's tough i mean woody's kind of gone
now
so it's like i mean i was listening to
george gershwin the other day i'm like
is this allowed to listen to
right song from manhattan yeah yeah it's
tough
there's got to be a place in hell with
some great entertainment you know
it's so good oh yeah and then like when
our country is doing two hours at the
club tonight
you gotta see cosby's new [ __ ] right he
addresses it
[Laughter]
he addresses it that's great
oh yeah that's gonna be gold in hell
hell's got good entertainment yeah then
harvey will be down there he'll be
producing
you know it's gonna be amazing like [ __ ]
once we get
tarantino down here the movies are gonna
be incredible yeah
the only problem is now they got made
off and he's taking all their [ __ ]
their money in hell [ __ ] madoff he
went out man
82. it's weird so i was reading about it
and his
wife ruth i think got 2.5 million out of
out of it like he returned
well i mean oh like she's lucky she got
two points yeah
it was uh 18 billion or something but it
could be the numbers wrong there or
something like that
yeah so most in history the most in
history he [ __ ] ruined ellie wisell
the writers
really this guy survived the holocaust
and then he gets [ __ ] over by his own
people
whoa bernie madoff
[ __ ] him out of 15.2 million from his
charity and his life savings you're like
man that's got to be
like you finally regain your faith in
humanity and then you're like oh trust
this nice kindly jewish fellow
wow horrible and then uh on jew crime
joined you crime man madoff now that
with madoff gone weinstein's probably
the worst jew
yeah epstein's gone epstein's gone
you're right it's it's but you know
weinstein i don't think he has long he's
already blind
i know he's he's really rotting away
yeah he's not looking good not that he
ever looked good but he looks like hell
but yeah you're right that's so crazy
the most in history but
i mean he is the michael jordan of of
swindling
yeah he's the mj for sure oh yeah he's
the greatest of all time
greatest people i mean it's an insane
amount of money and then
he got big people with it oh yeah kevin
bacon spielberg
oh yeah yeah some say the biggest i mean
he got the smartest and most famous and
biggest whales
and almost got away with it he had a
minute there for a second he got
[ __ ] because of the financial crisis
is that what did it i think that's what
did it because he was floating under the
radar and then also
i think once the financial crisis hit
people were like no we need our money
back and he was like
ooh this is awkward whoa i've lost all
of it
oh wow see the way he gets you is he's
so smart cause it's all ego
cause kevin bacon goes who's his roster
i gotta get in with this guy and then
they go i wanna be in the club and then
he gets that guy and then he gets
spielberg and then he gets the next guy
and it's all ego
he's a genius yeah i mean he really
he really got away with it for a long
time now his wife
is like this she's living in some weird
it's funny i was reading this it was
like
classic new york post like i got to read
the new york post articles but i was
reading about her and she's
you know in some weird kind of upscale
town she got a lot of money out of it
but not enough to be
you know she lost she's miserable she
lost both her kids one commits suicide
the other died of cancer
whoa you know it's it's a terrible
situation she's in
just like mj though if you're gonna make
it to the top you're gonna have to ruin
some relationships you're really pushing
this michael jordan
man all the greats their family hates it
i think i think mj's kids like him
better than madoff's who are [ __ ]
if they're hanging in hell right now
they're like no i think at the end
she has to make a choice where it was if
you visit dad in prison
we're not talking to you right so i
think she like she had to stop
wow well you think 82 which is not that
old in 2021 standards
yeah i think that stress just got him
that's gotta wear on
a guy i remember reading an article
years ago about madoff in prison and how
we talk about in prison
if you're a child molester you're
[ __ ] dead yeah but if you're
made off people were like how did you do
it oh yeah so you're popular in prison
definitely you know what we should have
done is like a frank abagnale thing he
was to catch me if you can guy
the fbi said okay this guy is a [ __ ]
but he's useful let's have him find bunk
checks and he worked for the fbi for
years
so why can't we use madoff i mean he's
dead but we could have used them to [ __ ]
over china
like we owe china 18 trillion or
whatever eight zillion trillion billion
dollars like what if he
did some numbers hey uh china how about
this this and this and i'll get you a
yacht in the the hamptons i don't know
he's in a meeting with china they're
like where have we heard your name
before there's something we don't trust
about this name
the name too it's just one of those
gifts in the comedy world like anthony
weiner is another one
it's just too good made off it's too
perfect
it's like if you saw that in a movie
you'd be like all right all right a
little on the nose
by the way do you see the movie no it
looks so bad they're making a madoff
movie
it's uh de niro and michelle pfeiffer
plays a wife
but it's like one of the things by the
way it is weird how they're like you
can't play other
groups but deniro once you become old
you can play a jew
good point and he was playing a jew yeah
good point
i know i never got the group stuff by
the way also pacino is doing like an old
he's doing like a black voice and
most of his old movies like sound of a
woman to like excuse me
i don't believe i will you're just like
what was that that's not is that right
right yeah no it's it's trans but you
can
but like elliott paige can she play a
lady again
or like i don't get any of the rules i
wonder
that's why a lot of it i don't think a
lot of this is going to stick and hold
up i mean how many
goals are there i don't know how much
more she's going to act how many roles
are there for trans people i mean
they just went it just went to francis
mcdormand right isn't that nomad land
doesn't she do yeah
oh is she i don't know i don't haven't
seen it i could be making this up i
heard it was boring
i heard it was boring too a lot of the
best pictures they look boring
they're boring and sad there's not one a
lot of sad a lot of
sad is in that's why godzilla's working
because it's just like oh i can't see a
lady in a [ __ ] trailer in the desert
give me a [ __ ] uh lizard with it with
a tail
yeah that's that's the way that's why
the the hollywood they're such
queefs i hate them because they're just
like oh this is what's in
yeah but i don't know go back to the
ticket sales thing let's let's go with
what's what
the lucas brothers movie was really good
that was really good jesus and the black
messiah was really good yeah
and not as sad as the rest even though
the head of the black panthers dies
it's it's sad but it's like it's it's
also
it's got like a departed type vibe yeah
it's kind of thrilling also even though
it's sad but uh
yeah i don't know what were we talking
about oh yeah uh elliott page oh yeah
when playing other it's interesting
where the line is because i don't know
i'm kind of just cause i remember
watching scene of a woman as a kid and
being shocked at pacino's voice being
like is that allowed
to do that yeah i'm like that's not a
white guy's voice interesting
like are you quite finished i'm just
getting warmed up
[Laughter]
like what is this a great movie too it's
so cheesy though
i was it's like a 90s really it's like a
90s picture
yeah philip seymour right right but dude
it's [ __ ] cheesy
it is cheesy but what about uh robert
downey jr
in tropic thunder that has just been
pushed aside he's like i think comedy
that it should be the goal post should
be different for comedy i agree as well
this is not made in sincerity this is
made as a satire he was sad he's
satirizing an actor who will do anything
right like that right are we not allowed
to make satire anymore
uh yeah well that's the scary part is i
don't know if we are but
i saw that movie in the theater with a
black guy and he was like
that was unbelievable he was it wasn't
even funny to him he was like i've never
seen a white guy do a black eye that
perfectly that accurately
with that much precision he was blown
away
that's hilarious i know and i was like
hell yeah all right that's the ultimate
compliment
that is yeah oh let's we gotta we got a
big ol uh
ad from fanny coming at you oh wait hold
on hold on
easy googly up
start that's the name of it oh god now i
don't see it and i'm freaking out
oh there it is all right here it comes
folks i have this too
yeah please edit this hey we might be
drunk is brought to you by upstart
do you dread looking at your credit card
statement every month
you better believe it especially with
the uh the sex workers i'm supporting
we don't blame you but upstart can help
upstart is the fast and easy way to get
a personal loan to pay off your debt
all online i've got so much debt i've
got student
loan debt i've got uh mortgage debt i've
got credit card debt i've got uh what do
you call it um
what's that other one the other debt oh
geez i can't think of it edit that
but uh yeah i got a ton of debt cell
phone
my cell phone went to hell and i got all
this debt so no cell phone dead
i got a back order i got blockbuster
debt i'm swimming in debt
folks you're a [ __ ] homeowner i know
i know i'm a homo
all right cut that whether it's paying
off credit cards or
are consolidating your debt over half a
million people have used upstart to get
a simple fixed monthly payment unlike
other lenders upstart looks
at more than just your credit score like
your income and your employment history
this means they can offer smarter rates
with trusted partners
five minutes all it takes for an online
rate check you can get approved the same
day
and you can receive funds as fast as one
business day
if debt is taking over your life it's
time to get a fresh start with upstart
tell them how sammy i'll tell you i just
lost some money with madoff so i'm happy
to hear that
find out how upstart can lower your
monthly payments today when you go to
upstart.com
drunk that's upstart.com drunk don't
forget to use our
url to let them know i sent you
yes gotta throw in this disclaimer here
guys loan amounts will be determined
based on your credit income and certain
other information
provided in your loan application and
now go to
upstart.com drunk
that is some good ass bourbon this is
top this is solid stuff and we're not
getting paid to say this one
so rowan's creek i've never heard of it
i'm a fan i'm a new i'm
a new subscriber rowan get in touch with
us we got to do some business mark and i
i don't know if you guys remember from
recently mark and i are going to make
our own damn bourbon
yes or why we haven't decided yet but
we're we're in the process of
of making our own drink yeah this is
probably
uh we haven't done it yet but if i if we
pull this off this will be the most
impressive thing i've ever done really
oh yeah
i mean anybody can write a joke
you've done a lot of stuff i just i if i
have my own liquor
on my shelf i'm gonna jerk off looking
at the label i mean that's
just i'm gonna tell my dad i'm gonna i'm
gonna post about it i can't wait
just something about having your own it
feels like such a successful masculine
interesting thing to have it is exciting
yeah i'm excited about it man we're up
there with clooney and hagar
and ron white and the other guy you know
all the top gentlemen that really went
downhill quickly
hey he's doing pretty good
what was he van halen i don't [ __ ]
one of those
he was one of those yeah yeah i think it
was van halen all right am i
they're gonna kill us if we're wrong
it's harry
it's it's van halen or the other one i
think it's van halen
it's gotta be i don't know i don't know
music well dude i i
yeah it's funny how a bad 80s music was
but it was so hip that like those
that's van halen thank you arenas thank
god yeah i don't know
guns and roses they were pretty good
that's 90s though is it
that's like early 90s oh okay yeah guns
and roses were the [ __ ]
i loved guns and roses man i know you
know what's i think i told you this
already but
from 2021 to 1991
is the same distance it is from 1991
to 1961. isn't that insane you're blown
away by
time i'm blown away by time it's like
that hannibal joke
yeah you got to take it one day at a
time he's like yeah that's how time
works
great job that's a great joke man dude
uh we haven't even done a peeve yet
we're just rolling we're just rolling
we're rolling well this this this is a
liquid podcast this just
keeps you going oh i heard a great joke
i had to tell you i heard this joke
yes please i i was scrolling through
youtube and uh one i was on a british
comic
and he said uh he's talking to his wife
and she goes you know a woman's work is
never done
and he goes yeah i guess that's why you
get paid less
wow that was right there for everybody i
forgot his name he's just some
like british nerdy guy in a suit and
that's a great you know a couple of
brilliant lines yeah
i love a good joke i've never heard damn
that's good
that's good and it got like the biggest
reaction
and they cut to some women and they were
like you know because it's a zing but
not a zing
you know it's he's saying you get paid
less but
he also kind of twisted it on you it's
really that's really
there's like as ricky gervais would say
there's like a novel in that book
i mean in that joke damn there's so much
behind it yeah that's a great joke
great joke that was right there for
everybody i hate when i yeah
those are i mean those are the best
jokes those are the best when you're
like how has that not been done
yes because everybody's like oh this
happened to me or i i got a story about
this but to have a joke that was sitting
there
whoo that was there for the taking i
know it tells us got a bunch of those
oh my god yeah the most probably the
most yeah
the best drinking jokes ever probably
yeah yeah
yeah i'm trying to think of one uh oh i
mean the [ __ ] the jaeger ads
there's a guy let's call him me yeah
he's [ __ ] the left eye of a pumpkin
if he didn't want it why was he smiling
at me oh
man there's so many lines and it's like
lyrical that joke is like there's like a
musical element to that joke
definitely what about the uh i used to
do drugs but that was way over there
that's like i didn't know you could tell
a joke that's like a whole new format to
me yeah he's the best
uh wait oh oh yeah all right and there's
the hedberg one that everyone [ __ ]
rips off
on on uh tick tock or whatever you're on
those are just like i used to do drugs i
still do but i used to also
that joke has been ripped off so much so
much so much yeah
that's a great that's the same kind of
weird i didn't know you could tell jokes
like that for me yeah
still do but i used to too like oh man
how did you get your brain to twist like
that
you know i'm heroin
[Laughter]
good point also a genius but heroin and
a guy who struggled like crazy
everybody's like hedberg hedberg hedberg
but you gotta remember this guy
like laid on the floor half the time
he's he bombed his presents they had to
sweeten it
like and yet it that presents blew up
so you never know you never know isn't
that funny though it was probably a
horrible night for him horrible he bombs
a special and he's like
i'm [ __ ] done i'm done it's a lot
like bill burr said my career is over
after the philly randy's like i blew it
and then that's what popped him wow have
i told you the mona lisa story no
yeah you told me okay okay last week
yeah
we drink so we forget one of us will
hopefully remember guys sorry if we
retell stories
yeah oh man uh yeah burrs
it's inspiring man you hit that i mean
you we've talked about this to death but
the idea that burr always says about
bombing in obscurity
i know killing it kill him that keeps me
going when i'm in
when i'm on a funny bone in the middle
of in albany i'm like man that was a
great set i wish somebody could have
seen no one knows i killed tonight
except these people
exactly yeah and then it's sad when you
almost wish someone
videotaped you you know you see a guy's
phone in the crowd you're like hey dick
put that away but then after a while
you're like i could have used that can
someone document that i'm doing well
in the [ __ ] in this rural outskirt
place exactly i'm in a strip mall
in the middle of nowhere killing and
nobody knows
strip mall comedy yeah yeah and i'm
gonna go back to my
shitty uh days in and jerk off and watch
the back to the future
rerun so funny so this gig so this
documentary came out i haven't seen it i
hear it's great jessica kirsten's doc
hysterical
oh it's all about female comedians but
uh
apparently i'm in it i don't remember i
heard you're in it too i don't
remember this as years ago i guess but
uh i found out because all these doc
all these articles i've been like people
like sending me and one of them
i remember this now but i played this
club years ago in uh
seattle and i stayed and
you know you know when you stayed in
hotels early on and you're like oh this
is good
and then you look back and like i can't
believe i stayed there that was
dangerous that was gonna put me up that
happened so much
i remember i i recommended this
uh club in this hotel yeah female comic
marina franklin hilarious she's sure
is a is a hotel good i was like oh yeah
great hotel really good
and then she gets there she's like she
called me this is not okay
you stayed here and then i i remember
like oh yeah a heroin addict did
pass out against the window yeah it was
like a motel style thing
like this is how [ __ ] beating down i
was like this is good yeah
there's a hotel right and it was next to
like a pancake house it was like there's
food nearby
yeah it's so much across a highway to
get the food
yeah well we came from such a shitty you
know open mics and
broke in new york like i remember one
time i opened for a schumer at gotham
and this is when she was like starting
to really pop and it was sold out it was
a big deal
and i texted her and i go hey there's
free pizza in the in the green room like
they put a free box of pizza and she
wrote
i'm making 50 grand this weekend and i
was like oh
[ __ ] i feel like such a loser that's so
funny yeah but in my mind i was like
what a score
yeah it's hard i still look at free food
and i'm like oh cool
but i also oh yeah i also
look back at some of those hotels i'm
like yeah i shouldn't but some of those
clubs
they also believe that that you deserve
that treatment
right where they would be like who are
you yeah exactly and they'd
they call you a diva if you asked not to
i remember i went back to that same club
and i said i don't want to stay in that
hotel again once i realized it
and they just wrote to my agents pass in
all caps
and i was like all right if that's how
they want to play it that's what wow
and then the next day they were like nah
you can come i was like we'll bring them
back
i can't believe this business yeah well
look we i love the club side splitters
the great club in tampa
one of the best clubs in the country
probably but be there in uh
june i think oh there you go that's
gonna be [ __ ] great yeah florida in
the summer time but 120
capacity yeah yeah there's a special
deal yeah
no mask on the door it's a snowball you
get thrown out if you wear one yeah
see someone wearing a mask on the
bathroom what are you doing
yeah well clan hood is fine but
um but how many years i've done that
club
six years in a row five years in a row
whatever it is i didn't get to
get out of the condo until maybe the
fourth year same
so yeah you just gotta do it a couple
times as an opener too i remember yeah
yeah with the headliner yeah and they
weren't happy about it
no the worst is when you headlined and
you showed up because we're flying from
new york and it was some local guy
and he got the good room because he got
there an hour i remember my birthday one
year and i was angry about it
he took the good room and i gave him
[ __ ] about it he apologized it was funny
oh all right all right i end up becoming
buddies with a guy too oh great
yeah how sad is that you took the good
room in the tu in the tampa condo
i know i know you took the slightly less
uh shitty room it was awful yeah but
that but that
club is great that's a great room great
room it's like a magical room there's a
6 p.m show on saturday and somehow
that's the best show good
yeah killer yeah it's a sp something
about that room
i remember i did a show once and chris
jericho the wrestler wow
and i was opening and he was he was a
really nice he was hammers
yeah to the point that he was like he
had like a roar of a laughter to the
point that i was like scared i'm like am
i gonna get heckled by chris jericho
yeah
like this is like noticeably loud right
and uh they end up being like the nicest
guy
florida has the weird it's like hulk
hogan lives in tampa you know and
they have all the scientologists [ __ ]
there all the wrestlers yes the weirdest
wrestlers porn stars and your grandma
yeah exactly it's a weird place but i
kind of love the city it's like weirdly
odd and charming yeah i mean that club
also just is so good
yeah comedy man all right i'm gonna read
a peeve here give me a just give me a
just a kiss a kiss just nice kiss a new
dick buddy
perfect right on the hole all right
here we go i'm gonna give you a peeve
and my peeve sucks
all right but i'm still gonna give it to
you um
so this happened to me the other night
and it's happened to me before
you come home from the airport i did a
long weekend in texas
you know the flights at [ __ ] 6 a.m
you get up at five you go to the airport
you finally get to jfk i get in the uber
and then the uber brings you to my door
yeah but you go okay
he's pulling up to the door and you go
all right it's right there that's the
door and he keeps
pulling up and i go no no that's it
right there oh you passed it you pet and
he keeps going like stop stop
and he's like oh and he pulled up to the
light and did a turn and i'm like
you could have just stopped there you
ever had that where they just won't stop
you sounded so frantic doing here stop
rape race yeah fire no i'm with you
uh i hate that [ __ ] i i hate
yeah i just want to like when you have
minuscules like
minuscule but yeah but that's what we
talk about these are first world
complaints
because we live in the first world mark
yes you know like
yeah i complain about that [ __ ] but
you're tired you've been traveling all
right right you got a rolly bag you got
your backpack
you're lugging more [ __ ] you're like
dude i'm paying you just please yeah
like why not
when i say that door they just keep
going and they're like oh oh okay okay
right here and you're like no no
i said that two blocks [ __ ] had it
with ubers too
i'm anti-uber i'm a yellow cab for life
dog really
i've been yellow cat yeah you are
yellows you have a bit about it yeah i
love them yeah i don't i've always been
yellow cabs yeah you drop i like a world
with no ratings
oh the rating is in the tip
i just don't yeah exactly but also every
once in a while
[ __ ] should suck a little bit hey i'm
with you on that yeah
yeah we want everything perfect yeah i
don't like the
i don't like the ubers man you know i
also jacked up the prices on this i knew
they'd do that they really did
they were like we're gonna we're the
cheap guys we're the nice guys we're the
we're just coming to town you're like
all right well you're destroying you've
destroyed the yellow cab community
the medallion is now worth yes that's
their retirement
you killed a [ __ ] entire how long
have yellow cavs been around watch a
movie from the 60s we got yellow cabs
these people are [ __ ] now yeah that's
true these were our people they were
part of our city we should have
protected them in new york there's a
scorsese movie about it there's no
scorsese uber
uber
he just wants to bang a 75 year old
woman you're like wow he is tormented he
is right
right it's al pacino playing an indian
guy for some reason
he's just an armenian uber driver taxi
driver
yeah that's true there's no uber driver
movie
no yeah taxis there i mean the yellow
cab is a staple it's like an iconic
image of new york new york
we're in a rush boom a man yeah you
don't [ __ ]
take out an app here he's coming five
minutes right
no you go out you wave yeah you [ __ ]
get in i'll tell you another thing is
they're
they're screwing you on the time not
only did the prices go up but the time
went up it go you go oh three minutes
we'll be here in three minutes and then
three minutes turns into four and then
it turns into six and then it goes back
down to two and then it goes to four and
you're like
just give me a time it's like someone
who doesn't know how to tell a story
right
i thought we were [ __ ] wrapping this
up right exactly that's a great great
analogy it's so true it's
i was always yellow cab i like the idea
i just like the idea of like i have a
bit about this how it felt like a
marriage and
and like and and you feel it's like a
single relation
la ubers are the worst though oh yeah oh
yeah cause that's everything out there
we have at least the yellow cab
alternative they're all uber
yeah yeah i always rent a car in la
that's like
oh i wish i could drive i could teach
that'd be a great episode we'll drink
and drive
we get pulled over it's for a podcast
look at the cameras
it's for a podcast yeah we've done a
carpool karaoke
maybe we get a crew that's pretty good
we should yeah a singing
yeah that's bridges bob seeger full
blast
and we're driving apart we'll do in the
parking lot
uh upstart.com you know we're doing the
ads
yeah you just blown into a breathalyzer
like a rock
ah yeah that's not bad i can teach you
to drive
could be fun i got a license but i'm
trash how did you listen
i [ __ ] sweet talk the driver dude
there you go i mean it took me i failed
twice
and the third time uh i was like please
don't fail me i failed twice
and she was like she laughed when i said
it and i'm like ooh i think i'm in
oh man and i definitely was not great
but i
i got in that is the most new york thing
of all time is
failing a driver's test but sweet
talking your way in yeah i was like
listen totes i need this yeah i got two
tickets to
hamilton oh you think it was that recent
jesus christ
oh yeah good boy i got two tickets to
[ __ ] tommy and broadway
that wasn't that long ago maybe a book
of mormon era book of mormon maybe
never saw it never saw it either we
should see it man well my parents loved
it and i was like ah
dude it's [ __ ] mad stone and trey
yeah they're geniuses they're gene
south park movies top five movies ever
oh dude
for me for we talk about comedies it's
it's top fi
harry it's top five right yeah top five
are you talking about what about team
america that wasn't bad either great but
bigger longer than uncut man yeah that's
true i love it but bigger longer known
cuts on another level
they are like an old kind of relic of
what comedy used to be just like balls
to the wall crazy [ __ ] a kid's dying the
sex jokes as a poop
you know a poop guy they're uncancelable
yeah they really are they can't they're
too good and and
i mean [ __ ] yeah i just i just like i'm
they're like two of the only people i'd
be scared to meet because i like them so
much
true that i i'm scared they were just
like i don't like you or something
yeah but i dude i love people [ __ ] on
basketball i love
baseball i love basically i love that
movie i love basically that's an
underrated comment yeah david zucker
yeah little [ __ ]
a little bit squeaky little bit scalar
[Laughter]
if you're ripping me 13 to 14 more times
i'm out of here
it's gold it's that it's i call it the
simpsons theory
the dumb people like it and the smart
people like it and that's the ultimate
kind of comedy like simpsons yeah it's a
fat guy falling
he's eating donuts it's funny but the
jokes are so well written
so subtle it's it's the way you want to
be like brian regan is like that
you know it's just yes dumb people love
ryan reagan because he's funny and goofy
but the writing is good too
all right this leads well into my rack
hit me wait i never heard your peeve
though did i all right let me do a piece
okay okay uh first off i did a show
okay i did a show last night
this is a comedy piece but it's a peeve
nonetheless just garbage people man
okay so i'm doing a show in shiva's room
in midtown and it's a good setup i like
the room
it's cool and sheba's so freaking nice
like so cool about it
i go up and this
woman just ordering food so loud to the
point that i'm like
hey i politely say hey do you just mind
it's very loud which i hate that i have
to even say it's so
disrespect and then i realized once
you're saying this you have no respect
in the room so i know if it doesn't stop
i got to get off
right and i never walk off stage but
it's got a point now where i'm like
if i don't see that i can win
i'm just not doing it i'm there to work
on new jokes
so if there's no if there's no way that
this is going to work
why am i doing it yeah that makes sense
so i give it a few more jokes she keeps
now she's talking louder to mock me oh
so and no one's doing anything and the
crowd's annoyed i can tell they're
annoyed
and and i say hey cut it out i'm being
nice about this and she and she goes uh
yeah i'm gonna order food so how about
that wow i was like am i i'm like you're
who raised you what kind of human being
are you i know you know like
this is this is our dream this is like
we love this and you're [ __ ] with our
dream
well that does that you showed up this
is what it is so like
you have to comply or get out garbage
person so i just say you know what
uh it's not really the right night for
me so i gave it a few minutes and i was
like i'm gonna get off and people were
like no don't get off and i was like no
i'm gonna get off
get off and i see tom mccaffrey a friend
there and he goes yeah you made the
right choice
that wasn't gonna get better that was
horrible the crowd starts booing them
our boy chris murphy
chris murphy who i love was there one
night when i got spat on on stage
wow i'm such a trend here yeah
this guy's bad luck that's the trend
yeah yeah uh no but
uh i get off because i was a kid when
this had when i got spat on but like
i get off and he was like the crowd
starts booing these two people
i was like oh good yeah i didn't think i
had you know earned enough goodwill
right i love that because we're not
we're spoiled on the road sure on the
road it's like
a lot of those people were there for us
we're the name on the thing
when you're on the bar show there's like
10 comments yeah you know there's no
trust
no trust we haven't we even earned the
respect on stage but also if i don't
have respect i can't perform
of course wait you know so i'm not a
[ __ ] substitute teacher i'm a
stand-up comic
yeah so they start booing them and they
get kicked out
oh and then i'm like alright i'm going
back up so i go back up and they were
good they were right
i had to open with how much how great
would it be if i [ __ ] bomb now
wow that that's a happy ending which is
rare happy ending yeah that is great it
was
uh the good guy won good guy won yeah
but you know
uh that's a p for sure because i mean
how many gigs have
have you been on where you're the the
feature is on and we're on the road and
you're like hey
you got to keep an eye on this dude he's
throwing fries at the stage or whatever
and they're like
he bought fries come on man
because i know they want the fry money
but like i'm also a human being
with feelings and whatnot you know
because they just want the food money
and you're just like a guy that's a bad
club
yeah no i mean chris was there when i
got spat on i was a kid and
i you know brought like common clothes
working the door they'd throw you up
sometimes
i was drinking when that happened by the
way were you no i'm
joking that that i was the one who spat
on it that was a joke i didn't make it
clear enough
but yeah uh so what happened what did
you say to get spit on
i uh i just was getting heckled and i
was just kind of like
this ain't gonna get better so i just
kind of
went at him he went at me i you try to
defuse it peacefully
he gets up and i hear and i'm like
here we go then nothing good comes after
me
nails me in the chest whoa yeah yeah and
then he goes i'm waiting outside for you
i'm like oh boy
so yeah big gentleman he was scary
enough
yeah yeah i mean clearly he's got more i
think i got more to lose if you're
standing up this you know so just like
yeah i'm not gonna
you know so i i'm there and uh you can't
you can't get the crowd back at that
point they pity you
yeah they just watch you get spat you're
killing me it's so
sad brutal yeah i remember that night
being like i wasn't good
but uh oh i'm sorry man that is uh i
watched my dad get spit on once by
teenagers and it ruined my life for like
two weeks really it was so traumatizing
because he's like my dad he's in a suit
i was a little kid and it was like a
racial thing and we gotta get better at
crowd work
yeah yeah he had some hack stuff
and uh you know he deserved it but we
got it it was like a classic new orleans
night we got off the street car and
there was like some
you know teenager hoodlum types and uh
they were making jokes and he was like
hey what are you gonna do you know
whatever and then you know he's got a
briefcase and a suit on
and we get off and they stuck the head
out the window and spat on him he's like
okay
all right you know and i was like i did
the right thing
i couldn't believe somebody could be
that mean to somebody who they don't
know
and who i like you know it was crazy
yeah it's because you only watch
good msnbc but yeah anyway really
let me tell you my wreck because i feel
good about this one i haven't finished
it yet but i'm two episodes down
out of three pbs hemingway dock whoa
i've never it just came out ken burns it
is
insane this is right up my anal i love
pbs doc i love hemingway
i love it oh my god i can't i'm gonna
watch this tonight oh it's so
you too it's like because you were
talking about
the smart people get it the stupid
people get it everyone gets it that's
hemingway
right anyone gets hemmingway it's so
short
though short those succinct sentences he
gets it across
it is perfect wow and his life is so
tragic
yeah yeah i mean anyone who knows
hemingway knows it ends in suicide but
like
his dad commits suicide right his mom
was a [ __ ]
right there's one part where his mom
writes in this long note about
she it's this long note to just telling
him like
you're this after he comes back from the
war by the way so he's already [ __ ] up
yeah and she writes from this long note
you know if relationships were bank all
you would do is withdraw
and it's part of me is like what a [ __ ]
the other part is like well we're in
there
you see where he gets it you know well
done that was eloquent
all right mom but yeah it really is
incredible
and and the affairs and yeah and every
marriage
like literally just starts [ __ ] a new
woman while he's married every time
wow and i think i want to marry you and
yeah and then his wife would be like
i mean you've got kids already he's like
yeah i want to be and it's kind of cool
to meet i mean that's not cool but
what's cool to me is that he just kept
going back to these horrible places
yeah span spain during the war right and
he needed that level excitement the
other part of me it blows my mind is
like
how i think about this a lot is comics
like the myth versus
the man i think about that all the time
right because all you hear about is the
partying and the cool stuff and the the
living in paris and all that but the
hangovers
and the sadness and the crying because
every every rise has a crash
yeah it's like a roller coaster and you
never really hear about the crash so
when you
hear these documentaries you're like oh
there it is you get to see it
not just that but it [ __ ] ruins you
like you hang out you want to hang out
with the per i i think he felt that he
had to become this myth
yeah that [ __ ] him up as a human too
yeah like once you become that but he
was so big
wow that it just it you feel like you
have to
be that guy and then you lose the charm
that people originally fell in love with
like everyone hated his first person
stories
yes because it's it's more when
there's a little distance in the third
person
it's kind of it's almost like a bit
where we take like certain liberties to
make the bit work
yeah when it's too much in the first
person it's too much of you i completed
a little bit of the middle
yes and i think a lot of comedy is
missing that middle they're just like me
me me confession confession you're like
i know but this won't work in
in denver like you gotta exactly it's
not brooklyn everywhere so
i completely agree and that's
fascinating i can't wait to watch you're
gonna love
it dude oh boy all right so true about
the man and the myth
i had a good run like seven years ago of
like
a lot of sex a lot of partying a lot of
comedy a lot of travel and all that i'm
glad you're not traveling or drinking
anymore well
but you remember that run i had but
there was a lot of sad nights too oh
dude
i know i never told anybody about those
but it's part of me occasionally i told
you occasionally but i i didn't want to
let too much out because i wanted that
kind of ethos cooking too i want a
little bit of a
of a brand going but there was a lot of
brand
what are you talking about but it's how
everything works you're calling your
agent
i got a new scoop here i'm working on my
brand what's the brand
i've been [ __ ] a lot and drinking too
much like i don't know i love the cells
really well i would show up to gigs in
the middle of like
north carolina they'd be like we've
heard about you buddy and they'd pull
out a daiquiri machine that had dust on
it and i was like
here we go baby and i had to live up to
it and i i think uh i learned real quick
that there's a real
dark side to look at madoff i mean he
was on top of the world at one point
epstein on top of the world you just
drank too much why are you comparing
yourself to epstein what the hell is
going on
that guy was living the dream for him
that was his dream and he made it
and then of course the crash that's a
funny way to describe i've seen though
he's on a sex island miners like living
the dream guys
but it makes you realize can you do it
yeah can you go to your top and be what
you want to be
and all that [ __ ] without the downfall
well there's a selfishness in what we do
like i think like the writers like
hemingway was living in cuba where
there's peace and like
he needed that uh he needed the peace to
write but he needed the craziness
to be inspired and i think with
stand-ups
we need to be in constant motion that's
why this pandemic's been helpful
so we need this motion to write but then
it is a selfish pursuit ultimately it is
hard to have
stability at home and we crave stability
at home because we're on the road all
the time
yeah but we have to be on the road to
right like
we're not gonna be good if we're not
doing the road at this
totally totally 100 man but that maybe
that's why comics
don't a lot of comics i don't know this
five
who keep being great most of them
you know are amazing and have a good
album second album solid third album for
them [ __ ]
yeah and you go what happened there i
think they found happiness they found
happiness yeah
but you need a balance you need a
balance up and down up and down
i sometimes find happiness and then i
feel like where the where's the material
yeah yeah which is a really unhealthy
outlook it is
but i do but the material makes you
happy so it is a balance the sad [ __ ] is
when you see me if i go through a
breakup and you're like
man i like your new jokes yeah yeah
right like if i see you and you're going
through some [ __ ] i'm like man
but i do think we can have it i do think
there is a way to have it all i just
think we haven't
i think there is i think there is yeah
it's finding
you you want to be up here and you don't
want to be down here but you just got to
stay
kind of up and down up and down up and
down in the middle it's doable and
there's some
because you can't have the sun without
the rain or whatever the [ __ ] it is
so you have to have a little bit of
sadness we're trying to have this
perfect life and we're trying to live
everything perfectly but it that's
actually making you sadder
if everything is a 10 and nothing's a
10. yeah so
you need something to compare it to
that's another thing i don't want to
give too much away from this doc but i
loved it so much that it's
there's a he has an affair with [ __ ] why
i don't know why her name
hemingway and matthorne what's her name
the
i wrote it down uh god she's like
the writer that he wrote her name down
all i know is i went to club martha
gelthorn
oh gelthorne yeah so he has affair with
her and it's like they're great when
they're in the war together
but then once they get a house it's
trash and i'm like is there never that's
so
he he just believed also like all right
so they're in a house together
it doesn't work they're in a war it
works there's something [ __ ]
hilarious about that well that's very
you
well you you like a little adventure or
like an introduction
i like an adventure yeah i'm an
adventurer same
same with the same but also he believed
and there and there's
unfortunately i think an inkling of
truth to this
that the nicer a woman is to you
the quicker you you you're a little
you're bored basically yes yes if
someone's too nice you're kind of like
it's
it all goes back to that groucho joke
yeah great joke
i wouldn't want to be a a member of any
club that would have me yes exactly so
genius so you're kind of like i'm you're
accepting me
i'm good right right it's so true and
that's a very
comic way to live yeah it is funny
man my rick sucks what's your compared
to that i i mean that opened up
at least i like uh salute your shorts it
was on nickelodeon
now uh i watched first of all i watched
the we work doc
which is it's pretty good yeah but the
the cool thing about it is
the guy who swindled everybody is this
like
it's the same archetype of
firefest guy billy mcfarlane uh
uh what's the other guy uh the the the
thomas what's the dale the car the dale
with the trans one i like that one a lot
same thing that this confident person
coming in
that's a great that's a great hbo dog
great hbo duck duploss brothers from new
orleans
but yeah uh so it's the same person like
this tall good-looking charismatic
confident guy who knew nothing but would
just
charm the pants off you big smile and he
got everybody's money
and he got out right before the pandemic
and then they found out he was full of
[ __ ] but it was too late because he made
all he made billions
it's not just being like it's just
playing the right part
it really is theranos elizabeth yeah
that's another one i mean [ __ ]
she just showed up looking like steve
jobs and like well she must be
she must know what she's talking about
she's wearing a turtleneck yeah exactly
it's incredible how you just show up
looking the part in that yeah and that's
enough like confidence goes
which scares me because i'm like i know
you know and then you're like who
swindled me
but then you're like we're not those
dudes in meetings we're kind of like a
little more like
so then you're thinking like was that
the good investor right
the guy just shows up like look i'm i'm
[ __ ] my suit doesn't fit right i'm an
idiot
yeah then the guy who's trash shows up
like i got you guys
exactly i know you and that's the guy
who sells and we don't
yeah we're here in a furniture studio
man this is this is this feels right
this feels and we might have our first
guest next week which could be very
exciting
it'll be a surprise and yeah it's a good
one it's a goodie
yeah but the other dock is this art
there's a thing on netflix about
stealing artwork from the boston
museum here it's great it's pretty great
yeah yeah it's great my mom was a part
of
this like art theft yeah and i'll talk
about another time
so yeah my mom's an artist but it's uh i
never knew that
are you serious i don't know like
painting i've showed you the fannies of
hers absolutely
man when i was uh hooking up with her
she never mentioned
i'm not gonna yes and you banging my mom
that's not a that's not a yes and improv
i'm gonna try that improv shows your mom
where where should i be inside your mom
okay
no no uh yeah very cr i heard this doc
is great
it's good it's well done and you think
it's going to be these james bond i
don't want to give anything away but
it's like these two mooks and it's
[ __ ] great
i love it all right but hey what uh
email us hit us up uh
send us your peeves your wrecks your
drinks whatever you like at um
we might be drunk yeah and also yeah we
might be drunkpot gmail.com
and hit up the patreon uh patreon.com is
that we might be drunk on patreon
we might be drunk pod on patreon
patreon.com we might be drunk pod
and uh should we do a quick bid or what
oh yeah what should we do
yeah we should do it right i guess so
yeah
uh mine is quick i got nothing i got a
quick one maybe
okay girlfriend caught me looking at
she's looking on my shoulder and i'm
looking at like instagram models
you know for some reason if you push the
search button on my instagram it just
puts up beautiful women with huge jugs
and fat asses
i wonder why that is yeah yeah i wonder
how that algorithm figured
that out i know it's that and seinfeld
bits
sounds like it doesn't know you at all
man what the [ __ ] so i pulled that up
and i i wasn't even scrolling through it
was just up and then she was like oh
what are you looking at and i was like
oh don't worry about that
and she's like you know those women uh
no no women look like that
and i was like yeah that's why it's good
that's why we're looking at it because
all the rest of you look normal
this is like exceptional that's the
whole point of being a model
so that's something with that that's
funny yeah this is this is jessica
rabbit level [ __ ] right right i mean
it's a ferrari like
it's like saying look these are all
hondas out here this is what normal cars
are like that's why i'm not looking at
the honda i'm looking at the ferraris
is unattainable that's why i'm looking
yes yes
exactly i just want to know what it
looks like right right
yeah haven't had a chance to drive one
but if someone offered me
yeah i'd pop in i'll do a test sure test
yeah
see how big the trunk is pop the hood
but yeah yeah shoot some motor oil all
over your tits
now uh yeah yeah so that would that's it
it'll be a quick one like that but the
whole point let's do a quick one too
then if you're doing a quick one
it just popped into my head oh great
it's an old idea i never tried on stage
but i think there's something here
uh some on the subway and it's kind of
packed you know and
and this woman goes you know in my day a
man would give a seat to a woman and i
said well you know i'm very progressive
that's perfect quick one all right i'll
try that i'll try that tonight
and there's a lot behind that too do you
want uh
silver or do you not want silver you
know something there we'll give it a
shot
definitely thanks for listening guys i
think we got a studio now so hopefully
we keep rolling here and uh
tell your friends about the pod this was
fun in person there's
it's a better vibe i think a person is
better people like it better
it feels better the drinks are flowing
uh
this is good bourbon right great bourbon
thank you sir
good choice but we got to mix it up next
week so we'll see what happens
thank you brother and uh yeah keep uh
and look if you if you got a
i'm excited for the liquor that we're
gonna make yeah that's gonna be fun
we got our own bourbon we need a name
and we need our own cocktail but we'll
get there
we got to think about i mean i think we
do a a version of the old pal because
it's underrepresented
i like that and we're all pals so it's
perfect but we need a name for the
liquor
we'll come up with some we got a few
ideas uh what is it late late show
or hell gig i can't remember it but
something about old pals is kind of fun
yeah yeah all right we'll figure it out
figure it out
thanks guys thank you guys cheers